It's worth doing a quick recap of how we expect the parameter this to behave.
Again, it's almost exactly like an input parameter.
But rather than being bound to the value that is supplied between the parens,
it's bound to the value that's on the left of the dotted call time.
So this function is going to log first ob1 and then ob2.
Here are the call time parens and this is the binding for
the first positional parameter.
And here we have the call time dot and the binding for the parameter this.
Back in our example, these are the call time parens.
There's nothing being passed in and bound to positional parameters and
here we have the call time dot and the binding for the parameter this